this is the legend of the gobblewonker
any worse could be legend of the over
theme ah ah I went with that reference
anyway um so uh the code at the very end
I believe said be sure to drink your
Ovaltine
uh no actually it was next episode
return to bud Iowa which I thought was
my guess it's a they said butt out
anyway so this isn't a blot yeah you
were making beaver jokes like throughout
the whole thing like oh hey gratuitous
beaver shot oh he got they got Bieber on
his face that's the first time not a
porno I've said that and so on and so
forth you know I'm watching a Disney
show okay I got summer all right
I do this episode did have as well as a
lot of episodes a lot of stuff again we
just serve Co really Disney I love how
he has to wear an ankle bracelet by the
end I love how they do counterfeit money
and I adore the line who wants to wear
blindfold yeah right in my intro the
intro I was just like wow counterfeiting
alright we went there and is like
alright well I'm more fun this time who
wants to wear blindfolds in my car this
is stuff right my wife seen a few of
these episodes and a lot I like she like
to find she just turns meiko's this is
Disney I'm like right awesome did ya
know it's um no actually gret I I am so
in love with what an awful awful person
grunkle Stan is yeah oh and you might
figured out why he's called grunkle
because cannae of it I did while we were
watching it I was like do you think he's
just called grunkle Stan because he's
grumpy uncle Stan and it's kind of um so
this episode uh grunkle Stan wants to
take them on a fishing trip for that
legitimate reason it seems he actually
just want to bond with them because he
had no fishing buddy he's gutsy keeps
getting turned in by the lake police and
so I just which is what led to the just
wonderful scenes of him being just an
awful human being yeah my favorite is
the two grandkids are just like we won't
you grandpa
Oh
oh um so but a different maple they want
to go find this the sea monster that the
crazy old man comes up I forget his name
I'll try again next time um comes up and
says you know oh yeah this is monster
and everything so they were gonna write
it had the Goa soos to try and find this
monster high jinks ensue and it turns
out that the crazy old man was the one
who made the monster cuz he just wanted
attention
pretty much oh the moral of today's
story is in Han said it seems a bit
contrived but there though my favorite
is the first thing they asked I was like
these kids have the wrong priorities cuz
you know to Frieza it was kind of like
scooby-doo it's like they pop it open
like oh man Willard you know but they're
just like you built this dragon why and
I was like why I think the real question
is how yeah does he ask again after was
it yeah afterwards he goes wow and
there's still like why oh no how so of
course they go in the enemy like oh we
should spend time with grunkle Stan and
you know steal people's fish and get
arrested again and stuff like that
um so okay so again funny episode um a
lot of good laughs um a lot first in
this one actually a lava I think it's
the first time I've ever seen a beaver
attack on any solution show brystol
beaver stick yeah this is like Hoss very
random uh it likes it some great jokes I
love the I love the glass being moved
across the lake on the tooth oh that one
I actually was almost just like I was
like wow that's like something just out
of Family Guy yeah so wait but funny
with it was funny um the Lysa a lot a
lot of characters realize like make
their first appearance in the show the
two cops make the first appearance what
I call the gem boys I'm sure I have like
another name but oh my god that was so
funny no no it was like wow I totally
dropped into like a 1985 anime be the
background was very easy yeah when she's
in jail sure the animation style event
oh it was like oh my god I'm six years
old no that they come back again they
are that they do a lot with them which
is so funny cuz it sounds just a
throwaway joke these two boys in a car
but it's like you just know they love
the design they're like
we got to do more with these and they
really they have fun with it later
scenes with her like I fast very fast
she's Mabel's become my favorite
character because she really like she
thinks like I think like it's like would
you do a $500.00 I'm like yeah probably
the giant hamster and I cut two dippers
and he's like getting some interview and
he gets some sort of little reward I'm
like lame hamster ball Oh yellow-bellied
see dress like India Jones for the ax
stubble I love that his fantasy look how
she busts into his fantasy that why
won't you interview me in VAM stir um
the yes the first appearance of the guy
this is good um he pops up like pretty
much everyone on that Lake makes another
appearance actually um the father is
ruining efficient well no but it's just
interesting to you how I love and come
back but uh on there's one other thing
is writing stuff down no no cause a lot
of them like I never notice I'd never
know that's I heard is I'm like what are
you writing he's like there are things I
never noticed and like I'll forget if I
don't wear I'm done and I've already
forgot one of them before and I
remembered it so I guess my memories
getting better on the back of um when
they see the hamster ball and the
contest uh there is an advertisement for
a child psychic I did people say I know
what that's gonna be and then the one
other thing that was probably this was
probably an accident but really worked
in their favor okay so the old man is
like this genius right he created like
he's just a crazy genius and stuff like
that you know I chose answer to every
bad thing that happens in the old a
giant robot yeah that destroys things oh
you know and here they even say you know
in hindsight it's a bit contrived you
know it's just a goofy joke it's a way
to you know just well we had to link is
the exact same funny a clean no but it
actually is a clue dilated you I have no
idea they intended for it or not because
it looks like you'll show some punchline
to a joke but actually that genius does
come back um which is really fascinating
uh II don't want revenge of the gnomes
though yeah I'll be back don't even own
quim I'm like they'd better come back
they'd better be like this big revenge
plot involving know
no fur but like my two fav it's a
toss-up between Mabel and uncle Stan and
like it's really hard for me to chew I
do love how Mabel and like every single
episode has a new tacky sweater which I
can say for like a lot of animate shows
you know you have to keep that brand you
had to have them always wear the same
clothes so you can sell the toys easier
and identify with them but I love like
in every episode there's a new terrible
sweater and that just always makes me
laugh and it's always so tacky even in
the opening like she plugs her sweater
in I do like what a horrible person
grunkle Stan is but Mabel I think is
definitely my favorite character i'll
exuse - I there's something about the
idiot characters that just I don't know
I just like I like maybe they're very
they're very liberating yeah I like and
I guess I like grunkle Stan for that
reason too because he's kind of like
Basil Fawlty here uh what's his face
from black books
Bernard black yeah both getting away
with stuff yeah just why he wants to get
away the idiots and the jerks always get
away with the things that you want to in
real life but can't because you know the
authorities this is the man oh man yeah
no Mabel isn't I won those case she's
like Edie from cowboy be like she's like
the cat from Red Dwarf
I love characters they're just in their
own world and they just love it and
they're just happy over everything
it's the glimpses into a world I love -
and a little edge back something just
like Wow
Oh what you're on but I respect that
what I love that how you know the show
obviously you know has a big 80s
influence it we can't act like the 80s
and 90s are not pretty friggin alive and
well nowadays I mean like this gen like
the generation growing up now kind of
like well that's a such a hodgepodge of
identity and it cancer reform its own
maybe it will there's a reason for that
it's because we're the content creators
now well yeah our generation is jelly
but but they're still allowing it you
book what you know if you look at a
chart like focus groups the stuff they
still do but everything is bagged Ninja
Turtles transformers My Little Pony I
mean it's all back so it is interesting
how like Mabel has these flashbacks in
the 80s she wears sweaters like the 80s
has earrings like the 80s and it's
that little kid think about some of the
things we grew up on though we still had
things resurging with the Flintstone
kids yes you know snowing you know like
basically that was their version of the
second round and I felt that actually
was probably more original than what we
have now which is here's the exact same
idea actually you know you just updated
even thinking back to like the Ninja
Turtle cartoons and stuff like that yeah
they said Cowabunga eat pizza and
radical dude all that stuff but like if
you remember like a lot of the villains
and the criminals as if they had the
fedora hats they had the trench go they
went yeah sure yeah and that's very much
the generation that the creators grew up
with you know the variant that was the
baby boomer generation was you know that
one outer so yeah so maybe it's always
been going on the more I think about it
uh but there's a very distinct you know
80s and 90s influence there like you
savvy its go yeah but the age of the
creator looks our age if not a touch
younger uh you know as I mean it's like
it's no doubt like well if you can work
I mean if you grew up in the early 90s
you still were exposed to the 80s for
one thing the 80s died a slow death just
like addicted the 90s died of it I'm not
convinced they're dead now they're like
really trying to come back yeah but I
mean well no not they're not necks like
if you grew up with it it's like really
what we consider the 90s I don't think
really died probably to like 2004 or
something I just don't feel like when I
watch shows from the early 2000s it got
that 90s holdover yeah I mean a lot of
decade but I'm not even sure what 2002
2010 was about when I think culturally
I'm like what the hell was boy bin Flay
would ya know a man's a big thing yeah
yeah I know the yellow hands bands like
the boy bands and I feel like I feel
like now the millennial hipster
generation has its own identity that's
forming but like I am what that was from
2000 to 2010 me that's what it was maybe
was being formed and we you know yeah I
get like I can I can look at the 80s I
know what the 80s is I know what the 90s
is I know what we've got now I don't
know what the hell we had from 2000 to
2010 so yeah fair enough
um I'd say tell us in the comments
section but I'll probably forget that
this is being released cuz we're filming
there's a month ahead of time yeah where
it is just to clarify like we are
filming this like you're pretty much a
month ahead of this
November 14th yeah so I mean it's it's
if there's something like why don't you
address this that just happened last
week that's why now I cuz there's so
many this even like Adventure Time
they're shorter yeah these are really
good but I'm like I'm like watchings I'm
like home hands like a half hour right
away yeah I kind of forget how long it
yeah so doing the half hours long now
cuz the internet with the shorts with
Adventure Time and stuff it's like oh
yeah like these are what are you talking
about your shows a normally half hour
long no no that's what I'm talking about
with like you know like the shows that
we divvy logs where they're usually so
sure with Adventure Time and it's like
oh yeah these are like a half hour yeah
so it makes sense for us to do it well
ahead of time so we don't get like if we
want to release these every day over the
course of December we're just gonna have
to start now yeah so um ya know funny
episode lots of lots of characters
introduced that you don't even know are
gonna be continuing characters which is
great uh and um yeah any other closing
thoughts uh Cara Lee thing I just
thought it was hilarious pretty much the
whole way through yeah I got covered
mostly everything I would have again the
atmosphere I just love this universe the
you know the monster being robot
particularly the sea monster I can't
feel like that's been done a lot like
particularly in kid shows and anime
shows and stuff but what I like is like
scooby-doo to me well yeah nobody that's
the old dude in a but what I liked it
didn't suck out the fantastic element of
it cuz he's done this like a dozen times
before it was anonymously a monster at
the end there was that supposed to be
the robot that no that's true and then
there isn't our sea monster at the end
um which I'm curious what they do with
that cuz I don't think he's come back
yet so I'm really curious with that um
so yeah good episode and we'll see you
in number 3